先生 人格者の香りというのはですね
人格者のエネルギー 波動とかエネルギーとか
そういう言葉を使ってもよろしいんでしょうか？抽象的でよくないですね
人格者の香りという言葉を使われましたけど
その香りというのをエネルギー波動とかエネルギーという言葉を使ってもよろしいんでしょうか
わかりませんね 私は大体必要な単語の中で喋ってますけど
時々そういう単語を私も使う時ありますけどね
その時は必要で この場合は全然それはなかったんです
この場合は波動やらエネルギーやらなんとか言うと
すぐもう変な方向へ行っちゃうんです
あとは小さい子供はですね
人格者の香りというか
どんな匂いとかって  それは聞かない
それは聞かない  あとそれからあの
死んでも道徳を守るっていうお話にあったんですけども
時々やっぱり人の非道徳で非道徳的な行動が目についちゃうんですけども
そういう場合っていうのは
以前のダンマパダにもありました通り
人のやったことをやらなかったことを見ないで
自分のやったことをやったことを見なさいということで
とりあえずはその自分の人格を磨いていくということを中心にしていくということでよろしいんでしょうか
だから人がやってるかやってないかっていう試すこと自体が非道徳なんですね
一応 みんな正直に頑張っているのかとかね
ごまかしやってないのかとかね
そういうことばっかり考えていること
性格自体が非道徳なんですね
なぜかその人は 2つの態度をとるんです
みんなやってるんだからいいじゃんという立場と
あるいはこの連中はけしからんだと
とんでもない連中やと言って
もう破壊するかと どっちがでも非道徳でしょ
社会を非難して もうあれこれ管理して抑えてやるとという大胆な態度も明らかに非道徳なんです
みんなやってるんだからね
あんたもやってるでしょ
だから私がやって何が悪いんですかと
あんたもこの間嘘をついたでしょうに
という態度とどちらかで
どういうこと？ 2つの態度も非道徳なんです
だから他人のことは置いておいて
自分がやっているのかやってないのかっていうことを気にするしかないんです
知らない人に教えてあげるということは
そのカテゴリに入りません
無知な上に道徳を破っている人は
もうそこは辞めてもらうとかね
そういうことはまあこのカテゴリに入りませんだけど
しかし 自分でもやっているんだったら止められませんでしょ
例えば何だったっけ あれは痴漢という行為がありますね
自分がしょっちゅう痴漢やっていて
で 誰かがもうもうそれやろうとして
自分あのね そんなことやめた方がいいんじゃないんですか？と言えますかね
言ったらものすごい偽善もいいところでしょう
なんかそういう人は結構いるでしょ
もうむちゃくちゃ自分に対して悪い悪いことしながら
ものすごい他人の過ちだったらうるさいこと喋るわ喋るは喋るは
日本のテレビ局のワイドショーみたいに自分たちが何者かと聞きたいんだけど
だから例えばワイドショーなんかでいっぱいこの社会問題についてもうもう何週間も一つの事件が起きたら
もう何週間ももうこれで食べてるでしょ？みんな
でも食べて もういろんな人を呼んで
もういろいろディスカッションやってやって
何一つも答えないでしょ
まあ再び起こらないことっていうのは当たり前の話ですからね
同じ事件起こるでしょうに
あれほど喋ってるのに無駄でしょうに
全部 何回私は犯罪を起こした人よりむしろこの人々の方がもっと暗いでしょう
もう黒いでしょうにと
この気持ち この思考自体
というケースもありますから
やっぱり 自分が道徳的かないかということは
まあずっとチェックする方が守る道なんですね
それを無視してるんだから
もうだからそれはものすごい強烈にもう問題は私にあるんだっていうことはね
それ聞きたくないでしょ
一応その話は だから問題は私にありということは徹底的にしないと
道徳社会は築くことはできないんです
すいません もう一つは愚か者っていうところにちょっと引っかかってるんですけども
事業なんかですと 母親が一人息子のことをですね
同性愛に他の性別にさせなさいと言ってて
もう一つは真実 真実だからといって何を喋ってもいいというわけじゃないということも言われてまして
そうすると愚か者っていうのは
どっちかっていうと蔑称といいますか
相手を蔑視した呼び方だと思うんですけどね
母親が自分の子供を愚か者っていうふうに呼ぶことはないと思うんですよ
ですから なんかちょっと引っかかってるんですけど
何に引っかかってるんですか？ お釈迦様がその愚か者って
今日のその定義言ったでしょ
愚か者しか言う言葉ないでしょうに
答えを言うなよという態度だったら
私を助けてください しかし
助ける方法だけ教えてくれないでと言っちゃうと
何言えばいいんですかね
私は病気です 薬だけ与えないでください
しかし治してくださいと
話になる？それ愚かじゃないんですか？そのすごい微妙なところなんです
ただ 俗世間で言ってるような愚か者っていう意味じゃないんです
もう一つは 智慧の世界でいうと
無常っていうのは見えないような認識パターン
みんな持ってます 無明っていうのは基本的な感情なんですよ
だから生命が愚か者なんです
そこを破らなくちゃいけないんです
そうしますと蔑称ということではないということですか
うん それも単なる真理の言葉なんです
今日の偈にはね その単語はなかったんですけど
先ほど道徳 10項のおっしゃってました
最大カーストの四十四億
うん そして  あれにはこの悟りの修行法を透けて解脱にまで透けて伸ばしてるんで
それは出家に対する道徳ですから
特に  五戒の最後の時に殺生と麻薬なんですが
治療に使う麻薬って今ガン治療に
治療は関係ないんですね
うん まあ治療の場合はまあ道徳の問題ではありませんだから
もう治療だからね あの
それは仏教では まあそれは道徳に
関係ないことになっていますけど
気をつけた方がいいところはいいんですよ
やっぱり たとえガン治療で麻薬を使うだったら
使わない方が正しいんですよ
一応 麻薬は麻薬だから
苦しいんじゃないかと
まあ苦しいのはどうしても苦しいんだからね
苦しみを味わった方がもっとよりいいんですけどね
でもそんな話はできませんだからね
俗世間では 仏教を知っている仏教の人だったら
もうそういうのは断ります
薬は で すっごい苦痛で痛い
まあそれはまあしょうがないと
病気だからっていうこと
この痛みを我慢する それよりもう麻薬を止めるということをしますけどね
それをまあ仏教徒っていうのはもういるわけじゃないしね
だから一般の世界ではね
しょうがないですね  よろしいですか？自由学というのはワンセットで大切なものなのか
それとも平等に自由が大切なのか
それとも一番最初だから大切なのかという感じに思われているのか
うん えーと あの 小さいところからアセンディングオーダーで並べてるんですよ
上昇順アセンディングで上る
うん えっ？昇順 うん 昇順で言ってます
だから殺生は私たちはものすごいと思ってるでしょうに
それすごいんですよ 殺生
それよりも危ないんですよ
2番目 どんどんどんどん言って一番大きな罪は邪見になるんです
まあそれよりも体のセット 3つと言葉のセット 4つと心のセット 3つなんですから
体の罪よりも言葉の罪の方が重い
言葉の罪よりも心の罪の方が重いという上昇順です
なんか引っかかるかもしれませんけど
殺生というのは だから罪の率が小さいんでしょうかと
殺す殺しは危ないと我々はすごく大げさに思ってますけど
殺しの場合でも そんなたくさん殺すってことはできないしね
だからこの そんな無量に大量に殺すってことはできないんです
与える迷惑の方もそれなりに制限されるんですけど
盗むということになってくると制限されませんね
社会に与える迷惑は もう社会そのものが崩れてしまいます
何か恐ろしい殺人犯が出たら
我々は逃げるなりに その人を抑えるなりに
なんとかテロばっかりある国だと
その国に行かないなりにとかね
なんとか守る方法はありますけどね
平気で物が盗るようになってくると
もう逃げられなくなっちゃって
で もうそれから不倫とかね
そういうもので与える苦しみっていうのは並大抵のものじゃないんですよ
それもね まあそれが人間もだらしなくなっちゃうし
社会になると まあ嘘を言っちゃうと
もう社会はもうもうそれだけでも危ないでしょうし
逃げる所なくなっちゃうんですね
それが個人の問題だから
個人に与えます 道徳順番ってます
19 8とか下の方がこう団体大切に大切に自分にしてった方がいいみたいなことが
一応10から始まった方が正しいんですよ
だから八正道の場合はそれを 1にしているんです
正見と それ完成すれば全部もうオートで完成しているんです
もう完璧に実践したいならば十で始まるんです
十から見れば他はもうほとんどもうちっちゃなちっちゃなもんで見えるんです
一から始まる人にとっては結構荷物は重いんです
でも愚かな人にでも殺生しないとか
すごい守られますから
やっぱり上長順にしているんですよ
誰にでも守られますからね
すごい理性のある人だったら
智慧を開発したくて知識広げたいという気持ちでいる人だったら
いきなり十に攻撃した方が
十に挑戦した方がすごい簡単です
だから八正道っていうのは仏道だからね
ブッダの教えに納得している人々とも
とっくに知識人であることはもう上まってるでしょ
理性あるっていうことはもう納得いったってことも理性になってるし
ではちゃんと頑張りなさいという場合は
正見で始めなさいというんです
まあついでに正語もとかね
では終了いたします どうもありがとうございます